uh hello everyone
as we said i'm benjamin guppinski data
and data scientist at agmax
and today we'll talk about evaluation of
recommendation system
and offline metrics um
and do need to start in saying that in
contrast to the previous two lectures i
dealt more with the more advanced topics
like
deep learning and um multi-unbandits
this one will go more to the basics so
let's start at the very basics
why do we need good recommendation
systems why do we need to differentiate
between good and bad recommendations
and why do we need to know or can we
know what a good or bad recommendation
is
so this would be an example for a very
bad recommendation
it is very important for us to know what
about to differentiate good and bad
accommodations because i sincerely
sincerely hope that no child or parent
would ever have to act on this
recommendation
and for those of you who do sincere
apologies
so we need to ask ourselves so if you
want to know what a good recommendation
system is we need to first understand
what recommendation systems are
accommodation systems usually go in two
branches one will be the complementary
branch and one in the similarity bench
the complementary branch deals with
items that are
complementary to the items that you are
viewing or interacting with
items that are in a very narrow field of
domain that
you are interacting with and so usually
depend more on the item description that
you're seeing
the similarity branch deals not only
with the items in such a narrow field
but also
explore and go to different ventures and
go and try to find new items
in order to enrich your experience so
for example if i would buy a camera at
amazon
i would like to expect i expecting also
to get recommendation for a memory card
of
case in order to hold the camera all
relating to the said camera that i'm
buying however if i'm going to in the
entertainment business
there is no such thing as a book that
they need to read in order to understand
another book
unless you're in academia that's a very
narrow niche however
if you're listening to some music you
want to find music that is similar to
that music
so if i'm listening to beethoven i'm
expecting to hear other romantic
musicians such as chopin brahms grig
and maybe explore a little bit and go to
the classical lake handle
but this lecture will do more in the
similarity branch
in the similarity branch all
recommendation system have the same
architecture which looks like this
i am interacting with one specific item
this item can be translated into some
vector of embeddings or features
this vector is entered into our search
engine
which looks across the entire catalog of
items that we have
and tries to find us the most similar
vectors in our catalog
now comes the question how do i know
that the items that i received from the
catalogue are relevant or good to us
if i bought the mickey mouse sticker i
might want to buy a mickey mouse t-shirt
but i won't necessarily need to buy
a mickey mouse toaster even if both of
them have a mickey mouse
so i need to evaluate them better
how do we evaluate them there are two
ways again to
evaluate things one on the online bench
and one in the offline bench
in the online branch the most common
thing is a b testing a b testing process
we don't know
is of course that we're taking a sub
sample of the user that we have
and we present to them a new thing
either a new model or a new
recommendation or a new data set
whatever you want
and this sub sample of the entire user
base that we are seeing
we record their interactions with the
existing height with the new
thing feature mode or whatever that we
are presenting to them
and we record and see the differences
after time
that we measure that experiment is over
we can say we can say and evaluate how
much
this new model is improved in converse
to the first model
another option is of course going to the
more expensive option and that is taking
the family and friends options
which is we're taking users that we pay
them specific more money and then they
give us
detailed evaluation of the model that
we're presenting to them
both of these so for example you can
have several testings at the same time
of course
because we want to so show model a b c d
e o a b c d d and then model e will be
our baseline which is the model that is
currently in production
all of um a b testing and bit for family
and friends or for subgroups have the
small problems that they are costly
either because we are paying the users
for more detailed information in their
time
or because we have to pay for mostly to
some
platform that gives us the services of a
b testing optimized whatever they have
some subscription when it costs
money also it takes time uh this time
it takes a lot of time to gather all the
data that we want to know
and we have to plan the tests in
accordance
we need to know what you're recording
and the recordings are mostly only
actions meaning we have immediate
feedback
but the immediate feedback we cannot
record all the information that we want
we only get
positive actions for them being how many
clicks or how many but
buying actions were performed if i want
to know
more implicit information like how was
the user experience how the item how the
model
um improved not only the buying
information but also the
level interaction or how it was
according to your taste
i cannot get that much information and
so the av testing
are limited um world young bandits were
explained in the previous exam
at the lecture and they deal with some
ways to improve the av testing that that
we are testing more smartly and more
improved way in the online
evaluations but since they've explained
more in the previous lecture i won't
develop too much into it if we go to the
offline bench
we have to ask ourselves first how much
we can see there are several algorithms
here but we have to ask yourself several
questions before that
one of them would be how do we evaluate
or how do we what do we expect to get
from these
offline on these evaluations
how much we are covering from the
catalog what is the quality
recommendation that we need to get in
contrast to what we are currently
viewing how much more do we need to
improve our precision
or our recall and how much is important
for us or at
all the ranking or the ordering of the
item that we're presenting to
the users what i mean by user coverage
we use the coverage mostly what we do is
take simple several
users we sum all the items that the
users sing
and we get a rough estimate how much the
average user sees from the entire
catalog that we have
so for example i'm pretty sure that i've
never seen more than
not even not closely to one percent of
the amazon catalog
however i'm pretty sure that most of you
have seen more than one percent of the
netflix catalog
especially now after the quarantines
while the reason that we also want to
show about the entire catalans know
which users sees from the catalogue is
the problem of the
pareto principle or the long tail
problem which is
while most items or most interactions or
purchases in retail industry would be in
the heads of these popularity product
functions where several millions of
billions of batteries are sold each day
their wealth is very small you do not
amazon won't get most of its money from
that
um from these interactions however
amazon does get
about 40 percent of its own revenue from
the items that they
is the the farther they are along the
long tail
where the items are more exotic but also
more
value if you're not going to retail
industry but in the entertainment
industry the long tail has the added
value of not only
having items that are more niche and so
perhaps less popular and less on demand
but they're more tailored to you users
who find
that esoteric students movie in netflix
feel that netflix has more options and
is better than any other platform of
entertainment movies
so we want to know uh so
now we want to know how now that we know
we want to improve the cut
which part of the catalog we will see we
want to ask which algorithm going to use
in order to evaluate our offline
metrics let's start with precision at k
precision at k is a very simple
classification problem you ask yourself
if i'm showing you several
items how many of those items are
relevant to you
relevance to you in this case will be
one either the item is relevant or not
relevant to the item presented to you
and you simply sum that the number of
relevant items divided by the number of
k that you decide of the item that is
being
shown so for example if i'm showing to
you mickey mouse in minimals
or minnie mouse mickey mouse and you buy
mikkem also mickey mouse is relevant to
your purchase
then you can say that the position that
k for precision at
two is have because there is one item
relevant in these two items that are
shown
of course the immediate thing that you
will ask yourself is wait but is the
ordering important
in precision decay this and this would
be exactly the same
because there are two items shown and
irrelevant if it's the first item or the
second item
both of them if only one of them is
relevant the same score
will be given we know that most users
do find relevance in the ordering and it
does
affect how the user buys or how much he
buys in the platform that they're using
users and so we want to improve the
ranking
so if we want to go to ranking we need
to take a different algorithm such
algorithm perhaps would be mean average
precision at k or map it k mapped k
takes the precision at k formula
and simply does it sums it across each
item
of the recommendation relevance meaning
if i am going to ask what is
k at method five the answer would be
what is the map
one method two method frame with four
map with five sum it all together
and divide it by the number of way k the
number of items i want to show
if we want to know what map it case for
the entire user base and not for a
specific user i will then divide again
that sum
by the number of users that i have so
for example
if a user won those five items
only three of them are relevant one
three two a one three and four
then map it one would be one method
three would be two because there are two
items relevant
of the three at the third position map
four would be
three over four because there are three
relevant items in the fourth position
sum them all up divide them by three we
get the map here we get average
precision of user 1.
do the same thing for user 2 who has a
less better result
we get the average precision for user 2.
sum them up and divide by number 2 we
divide by 2
we get a map of the algorithm for this
user base
the option the next question that you
should ask yourself is this why is it so
simple
most items aren't relevant or not
relevant there's a scoring there's a
ranking there's some
metric that you can decide how much item
is
the same or not the same how much a user
is enjoying the items
or how much he finds the recommendation
relevant
in order to make it binary i either make
a
arbitrary distinction saying that about
such and such
skull i'm saying it's relevant below it
it's not
and usually you're using that in that
problem
so in order to get in for more relevant
details
or relevant levels i'm going to go to
the different algorithms called discount
the discounted cumulative gain which is
dcg
dcg assumes that our relevance levels
meaning that are no longer a binary
problem but a multi-class problem the
function is looks a little different but
it's actually the same
there is a relevant score meaning which
degree of relevance the item is
and it divided by the log of the
location plus one
dcg also has the cinch since
sorry the relevance uh for each
ranking is different there is also a
normalized dcg which takes the
ideal dcg scoring meaning what is for
certain recommendation what we the ideal
ordering of
that of those items what does it mean
if i'm having this list of items
with these the scores of relevance i can
get the dcg score for each item
according to the ranking and ordering of
them
in this list get this g-score
compared to the id segmented ideal
ranking meaning
ordered ranking of the items according
to relevance
and dividing those two i will get the
normalized dcg
of course the closer it is to one the
more happier i am
but now comes the second now comes
another question
this means i have to order the ranking
of the relevance of items
but the catalog usually is not something
that stays static
all the time we'll get more and more
items to the catalog all the time we'll
have to re-evaluate them we have to
decide how much relevance they are
i'll have to reorder what is the most
relevant and less relevant item and so
the ordering in the ranking would be a
non-ending test and
it will cost a lot of time and effort
from us to maintain such a database
uh in order to in order to surmount such
a problem we need to attract
problem differently we need to attack
the recommendation as a regression
problem not as a ranking problem
when we attack the recommendation is a
regression problem we are saying two
things
if i say if i'm saying that i have some
score of the similarity between two
items
i can then get the ground roof matrix
that says for me how much one i think is
well
similar to another item and then then
can
take a model ask it how for one item in
each feature
to find the most similar to multiply it
find the gaussian simulation between
that item and all
other items in my catalog and then i
will get a matrix of similarity between
each item and each other item
in my catalog the this this matrix that
i'm getting from the model can be
compared
to the annotation or the ground truth
that i'm getting from
uh people who know the catalog button
can give me an actual assessment of the
data
or from people who i can ask to do it
for me if there is no crown truth
for such subjective items like how much
one book is similar to another book
the comparison between those two will
give me then the scoring of the model
and how good or how fit how improved the
model is compared to our previous models
in order to get such annotation that how
to get to ground truth
we went to mechanical turk and we simply
gave them this questionnaire
we give him the one song ask him to play
it
and ask him how many which of these
instruments is in that song
then we ask him to take second song
again asking them
which of the instruments are in that
song and then asking what is the ranking
similarity
the thing that is most obvious here is
the question what is this
why do we need to know which instruments
are in the songs it is irrelevant we
only want to know
what the score is so why do we ask them
the answer is simple we want to verify
that they actually listen to the songs
you want to know that they have listened
that they know that
they know about what they are talking
about and not simply a clicking random
buttons
mechanical turk is a platform of amazon
that allows us to go to the wisdom of
the crowds and ask them such questions
in that we are in giving them such so
many songs and multiplying the answers
and collecting the data of all these
songs we can then get the opinion of
several hundred people
about each song paul and as we all know
the opinion of one person is an opinion
but the opinion of a lot of people is
data
if we take the date of all these songs
we can then get
the ground roof or as close as we can to
such subjective matters
how much one song is similar to another
song
of course it is in the fact of the cost
but amazon mechanical took
is relatively cheap i think for each
song pairing it was nothing like 20
cents
um of course you as i said we want to
have several people ranking the same
sound pairs
in order to get the best in order to
make sure that no in order to minimize
the
noise that we have and get them as close
to the ground too as possible
randomly clicking the items is that i'm
checking that they're listening to the
songs and then clicking the
instruments that were in the song if the
songs were not
if there is a mismatch between the songs
and the instruments i know that the
annotation is irrelevant and so i can
simply avoid it
i only take the annotations that were
listened clicked right and it's the
instrument and so i know that at least
they listen to the songs
and then i know that the annotation if
not perfect it's
at least as close as i will get to it um
demo this dashboard platform was used
for
artists which we use for them this
dashboard has several
um features that we have thought would
be useful for them
one of them would be an often light file
would be sort of a demo
if i would present each of these models
now into production
and i want to know for a specific song
id what would be the recommendation for
each which
recommendation would each model give to
me of course according to the data we
want we might want to perhaps change the
similarity distance
or change the number of items that we
see but the
dashboard is online and live and so it
is very simple for them to evaluate and
to assess the how good each model
presents to us or not
the other tab that we have let's see if
it works yes
is to get a more detailed explanation
for each song
what uh the scoring is that we found as
the ground truth
the ground tooth can be changed
according to which annotators we are
using we can use several annotators we
can pay users we can use mechanical turk
it doesn't matter some of them were the
media team that we
got from artists that they happily
enjoyed that someone was going to help
them with the similarity search
and each model then can we can then get
results for each model and how much they
are diff how much they are different
sorry
compared to the other models
and get a more detailed information per
genre this detailed analysis perish
general
is of course important one second
in the more overview scale where you can
second
yeah we can then go across each genre
that we have
and see how each model scores in that
genre
according to the sample they have now
the
main added value of such a thing is of
course that
some models just perform better at some
genres
while they perform less well in other
genres this allows
the models this allows us to do two
things one go deeper understand where
the model fail where model
should improve or what it is or perhaps
what it is that the
la that model learned here well and
failed to learn here
is the problem with our feature
selection is the part with a feature
engineering
or perhaps simply we have made two
different models that each of them
is good for once part of the catalog but
not good
as good for another part of catalog this
can then allows us to decide either to
improve the models in order to find one
model that will
classify both classify best both genres
or decide for deployment reasons
we deployed this model for cinematic
genres whereas to deploy the orange
model
for the funk projeans
of course you know since we know that
such annotation is of course something
that will continually be added
as the catalog changes we want to add
them more and more we also allow them
to upload their cut their annotations
online and immediately dive deep into
them and understand where the problem is
and see which model fails or fares
better
in each kind one of the song pairings
that we have
and yeah as
let's to sum things up the problem of
the data is of course that the data is
something that changes constantly and
the data cannot be assumed to be static
we do not have label data similarities
not something that
can be easily easily assessed and once
even if it would be assessed it's
something that constantly changing if we
want to talk about
ranking because ranking as the catalog
changes again need to be reevaluated
once we go to regression problem the
data becomes static because even if new
data is found and more similar items are
found the less similar items are found
similarity score is something that is
given and will not change
one item is sachin touch point relevant
to another
song and this allows us to evaluate
different models
in future points because it is
irrelevant if the newer model have
trained on greater data sets
and found new and new songs as long as
the songs are
the previous songs are still there the
scoring can that
allows us to compare these two songs and
allows us to compare between the models
and how they
scored for each two songs that were
found the dashboard
allows us both to developers and
annotators and other teams in the
department and at least to develop to
decide which model is the best which
model
can be improved or why improved to get a
small
preview of how the models will deploy in
real life
and allows them to label future data and
whenever they want to
thank you and any questions yes what's
the main difference
between what you're doing here and
uh a similarity
with will films and stuff like that that
netflix is doing
i don't know what netflix is doing
nobody knows you have like some kind of
a model that you take like
recommendation system and then you find
like films which are similar in some
sense
and netflix is also
more dependent on online testing they
have developed their own in-house online
testing
dashboard where they're running i think
at any time any users
is undergoing 50 different experiments
from which
are they using from the movie to
whatever
by the way that's why the reason when
each time you go to netflix you mostly
see different things and you see that
the art changes constantly it means that
you were at some point one of the
testers so like
the main thing is like the theoretical
mode
are depending more on user experience
and less on the theoretical model
okay and your model is basically linear
it's more linear but on the other hand
it's more static it doesn't change all
the time
it takes less effort and it again
netflix can allow itself because it has
that amount of money in that amount of
resources
at least it does not have those
resources so basically you're saying
that since you're doing
offline you can use a linear model and
achieve good results
yes
no there are several models that are
running all the time but
as you see some models fare better at
some genres and compared to
the same model and you see that some
genres in the
another genre would be opposite we can
have several models currently only shown
two but we can have five ten
fifteen models at one co in parallel and
we get anything and then can decide
which one want to deploy
for the for each song genre
but you can do the clustering for genres
by
by the distance metrics by the way of
course i'm talking about the clustering
make more sense and how like how do you
maintain this complexity of following
using this dashboard like uh again with
some as i've shown you can see the
evaluation then you can sum by genre the
scoring for each model
and then you can assess okay i don't
know
foreign
pop and whatever model a is better for
genres cinematic and dramatic model c
is better and for metal model d is
better
so you're constantly like changing which
model manually
the model goes across the entire data
database
uh and everybody increases sometimes the
model changes or the
performance of the model changes as more
songs are added
of course some models could be decide of
course it allows us to know okay some
models prefer better some genres maybe
want to
go later again to the model and try to
improve the model so it will
it'll be better for more genres of
course john is the only demonstration
this can be used for anything you want
to do for movies doesn't have to be
genres it can be
any tag that you want to only as long as
it groups all your database in some
meaningful way
if you want to do it by bpm or something
like that it works the same
other questions yes i was wondering
about the instruments you said you were
just using them as a
measure to verify that um
i wonder if they had any value
for this thing they did not have
intrinsic value of course some of the
models models do use the
instruments as features but
so but these features are assessed by
the model not by the annotator
other questions
thank you
[Applause]